Trouve qu'il y a 1 vie politique
trop morcelée en France
et que vous contribuez,
vous, à morceler non pas la gauche mais la droite,
et que vous seriez bien mieux dans 1 grande maison.
C'est vrai que vous êtes 1 homme de droite,
vous, vous êtes la droite rural.
Oh me dites pas me la jouez pas,
je suis ni de droite ni de gauche hein,
non, et je me suis toute ma vie,
je suis 1 homme aligné comme l'était le général,
et je suis profondément gauliste et gaulien. Hmm.
Et aujourd'hui, euh,
si quelqu'un a envie d'aller chez les républicains,
mais qu'il y aille.
Hum. Parce que
si monsieur pense que les républicains
sont ceux qu'ils ont été du temps de Sarkozy,
ils se trompent.
Ouais, si les socialistes pensent qu'ils sont
ceux qu'ils étaient du temps du choc Valérie
c'est 1 destin,
contre Mitterrand,
c'est fini. Il y a 30 ans,
tous les perdis ont implosé
et moi au contraire,
j'en ai créé 1 de nouveau
qui n'implose pas parce qu'il est toujours en vie